you are not working today
hard work Oh fixes everything
you okay there
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
Nega fat CEO baby did something clog
your schnitzel chute
that's terrible arias mega fancy your
babies sympathy is tainted with
amusement it's not a problem
go my team can still take care of these
copycats for tea party celebration love
that good news of course your field team
will have to stop the copycats without
you because you're taking us in and
we'll sit and reset every sick day
I just need door no no work until you
gets a poop who's out hmm if I catch you
working sick you're fired
and if your team fails without you
you're also fired what call it a catch
number two have fun at home with your
man baby whatever his name is I want to
say Cody it's actually
we babies are having a crisis well it's
simpler if I just show you teddy if you
please Jimbo hit the Lights
you see babies aren't getting as much
love as we used to right behold our
mortal enemy no no that's exactly the
problem this is war
puppies are winning and babies are
losing bad news baby what are we going
to do you're going to help me
oh you still got it yay now your parents
will work for puppy Co so have you
learned anything from them yes sir
triplets go oh no what have you learned
about puppies puppies no Jimbo puppies
are evil Stacey be back the notes I
can't read what's it say this isn't my
team a musclehead a bunch of yes men and
a doodler exactly put that cookie down
cookies are for closers
[Music]
you